okay let's see four people joining us on
the live stream this is a internal
architecture meeting about our
repository framework otherwise known as
our resource system and let's get
started here
so the first thing we're talking about
is our formula repository and what is
this is this an actual test deployment
here yeah okay
nice alright so let's take a look is
there real stuff in here everything
should be working there a few minor
issues that I'll address as you find
them right so what some of them are
empty and we need to trim the empty ones
physics has content physics has a lot of
engineering has a lot okay I'm
categorized as magnetic frequency shift
well what is the why is there all this
junk at the top here right so we have
two dimensions of sorting one is this
category and one is the physical
quantities of the variables in the
formula okay well first of all let's
take a look at the actual formula so
first point is all these formulas so far
our algebraic type formulas grab back
yes Michael here yeah that's going one
one thing so for these with multiple
formulas or multiple equations we're
gonna lay them out vertically instead of
horizontally it's just not this one's
not updated yet are you sure that's the
right thing to do I think so aligned
aligned on the equal sign is the way
we're doing it right now
I would think okay all right are we not
linking these physical quantities and
things to something interesting for
example for the wolfman alpha output
about that physical quantity I would
think and also G factor surely has a
space in the name G factor also with
these physical quantities why aren't we
just writing out their actual names
rather than giving the smouched standard
form version
actually I've multiple suggestions here
um we found a couple of inconsistencies
in those two I think it's definitely
something we need to hash out still
exactly what they want but I mean
another question is should this allow
copy paste to a desktop for example
should this for look at this gosh
wow I think yes it should okay good
all right let's see what it does right
so so this is sort of like this
super the extended version of quantity
variable that we could trim out all
those options but they're really useful
so I don't stumbled all of that is I
mean in other words the why okay so
first question is why isn't this not a
formula data thing well the first
example I think ended you should get
what you see not something that
evaluates to it right so if you evaluate
that it'll be just like what you see
right we could trim out all those
options that are showing up red because
I know Jason can correct me if I'm wrong
but that's something that isn't really
documented for users at all right no
well that would be why it turned red
right should we be documenting it it's
no what is it
it's used internally by by formula data
to answer all the various little
questions like what is the canonical
unit that's Griffin and like the table
that's on the shingle that we were
talking about the physical cloning comma
that's generated from this metadata but
why isn't I don't understand why isn't
angular frequency a definite type of
quantity that then goes in and
understands what features it has I mean
why doesn't why it isn't wise an angular
frequency just a key that gives you all
this other stuff well some of it is
formulas specific default value for
instance okay well then where are we
going to get that from if we drop it
from here
within the repository we'll still store
it but what's it what's it doing in this
formula I mean isn't it useful in this
formula Michael help me no no no I think
like you could have let's see take
physical quantity mass and so mass is a
very general button but it might be
initial mass final mass neutral mass you
know there are many instant and it might
be information you want to have
available for various purposes or the
four values so we put them somewhere and
there's nothing wrong with putting them
as false options into an existing symbol
but this does not mean that quantity
variable and mass is the canonical
generic thing well I mean it's not
pleasant to have string things that look
like options when they're not options I
mean if we're really gonna have this no
but we did not have it it's just it okay
but what if we're gonna pack it in there
for internal purposes
why don't we officially give quantity
variable a third argument that's an
association where it can pack all this
information then rather than having the
majority of function wouldn't know what
to do with it well that's fine but I'm
just saying whatever is done with it if
you ever see it having it generate this
giant red mess is clearly not desirable
right if you just can do it everything
what was it I mean unless you think it
is merely an internal thing that should
be stripped on output basic thing okay
fine I have no opinion okay let's take a
look here so these things like angular
frequency I don't understand how oh I
see so this should surely be consistent
I mean it says it I get a frequency it
should surely be have a common name
that's similarly capitalized right
does that make sense I mean it's a
little goofy looking because in in the
right column we're listing the the
Wolfram language yes name for the
physical quantity maybe we just need to
update the header of that table mm-hmm
well but what what do we what is the
purpose of this I mean in other words a
lot of times description is not so
boring and directly mapped to this
physical quantity
a magnetic frequency shift from the type
but in this complete formula it's the
gyromagnetic ratio generically often
they will be very similar but sometimes
they will be substantially deviating for
metals of the names okay okay
well I'm saying I think we should be
common names do we have a common name
thing here we do don't we there must be
a common name starting working and
making physical quantities in addition
to basically swing arguments with in
quantity variable actually entities and
once we have entities then we can
associate seeing cycle name and also
things to them fine like what we did for
physical constants right okay but then
these things here should surely have you
know the same kind of copy mechanism
that that has I would think at least at
least the physical quantity part of it
sure right yes and arguably the symbol
should as well the symbol mode F yeah II
be the physical quantity with with all
its tentacles yeah okay all right now
what does this mean calculate
frequencies where did that come from I
thought it was a single frequency the
larmor frequency
what what is this doing here
and why are these italic and why are
there no spaces between the G factor and
the G word it looks like we've lost our
hyphens that's what the problem is there
with the G factor what's the - doing
what what do you mean - you mean colons
or there was a - between 3 & factor but
somehow that's that's a detailed issue
but specifically G factor but I'm asking
should be a space yes yeah that's okay
you see in the hint on the third floor
right why can't I edit I mean if I just
want to use tesslar again why can't I
just at the world so it's it's a hint in
that default because if every field has
a default the form evaluates immediately
well I didn't understand it immediately
if you create a form function our form
patient well we we can talk about that
bug in a second but if you so if you
deploy a form page with where every
field has a default and then you open it
it will evaluate that seems like a bug I
mean I can see either way being
reasonable but it should be something
that you can configure I don't think it
is maybe I'm wrong I conduct a car let's
see if you kill turn that off fine okay
now we seem to have lost the times ten
to the ten or ten well yeah the whole
yeah there's a bug that I've reported
for cloud but pretty much all the HTML
exporting fails on scientific notation
okay why is there an HTML export at all
is this as this did you write it with a
superscript and things I think the
default is a actual number not a string
I believe isn't that right Jason yes
well that's gonna goof up completely we
don't want that we want it because you
know it's gonna give some weird a
notation from HTML and we definitely
don't want that making sense
right well I mean one of the challenges
here is for a number of things we've had
to basically write a custom HTML
exporter Wow
like that table above where we have
these symbol names some of them are like
Omega star over Omega tilde have you
talked to the people who deal with the
HTML export because that shouldn't
require I mean there should be a way of
just getting taking a grid and
outputting it in that form right there's
and I didn't wanna wait for their
timeline so well what is that who did
you talk to about that you're getting
that done there's a take it up and I
think it's I'm not sure I'm not sure if
it's a sign I can try to find it who's
coming this the scientific notation
thing is assigned a Carlo it's really
but I mean that this thing is something
in Andres area knowing how to do that
export that's we have a lot to cover in
this meeting so let's let's just keep
going a bit okay so I don't understand
where calculate frequencies comes from
Jason's put together you know form
definitions for well we usually have a
few different frequencies in that in
this particular formula I mean their
frequency and angular frequency is a
known issue I'm going to address that
it's just not deployed here right now
right now it's expecting numbers and I'm
gonna fix it so that it'll properly take
quantities okay so none of this is going
to work because if you just put in if
you just put in numbers in all four
fields they don't work okay I mean I
don't even can't even imagine what one
kilogram is very big and one Coulomb
okay let's see what happens
why is it taking it forever to compute
something which is basically trivial
right so this is the other place where
we had to start making around HTML
exporting you can see it's pretty ugly
it's really ridiculously but yeah this
is silly it were working on it
this might be an old one let me let me
see if I can find one there is okay but
this is wrong in so many different ways
well that's disappointing
all right okay so let's take a look down
here okay
examples are currently done semi
programmatically and we are going to
have a process to go through and update
those by hand for launch okay all right
what does that process here I mean given
this page how do we get to off malphur
from this page for example there was one
of the things we discussed yesterday
with some people and we wanted to
discuss more with you right okay
various possibilities you might want to
go from here you might want to go check
us out using formal data you might want
to use we saw stander you might want to
go to example pages also so the most a
bunch of the things to be categorised
and clarified which one the most useful
ones right well I mean there's opening
this in the okay so one thing would be
yeah examples either opening them in the
cloud or downloading them for desktop
list
okay now the next thing is being able to
do the whole thing using wolf now fur
and potentially there is a string that
you could write which is the wolf now
for input string that corresponds to
this form is that not correct
yeah yes there's a bunch of background
like seashore noise of something that
sounds like a seashore but um okay but
so what would happen so let's say
I wonder what would happen if we well
let's see there's a thing without the
actual numbers filled in and there's the
thing with your particular numbers fill
then it might I mean which would be a
wolf now for query is that useful
I mean it's some yes there are kind of
poison coins I think
I thought typically has a little bit
more output from time to time but
generically while right now we are in
sync with alpha it's not obvious that we
always want to be in sync right because
these are formulas that anybody could
submit
yes exactly okay well I mean then maybe
what we want to do is for the ones that
are loved now for you know compatible we
should just have a link up here that
says you know which goes to an example
of now for example is that plausible or
not when there is one we don't have
every single formula presented as an
example actually only probably a couple
percent okay well fine but you can go to
the similar query page on alpha for this
formula yes right yeah so I mean maybe
that's the thing to do
we couldn't write so I mean if we went
there we would go ants number and that
would give us use as a formula know what
this was okay that was the physical
quantity Lauren's numbers okay
why is this taking forever what's going
on oh come on what is it doing
well this should
reported to the of Marfa speed people I
don't know what it's doing here but but
maybe the right thing to do would be to
have a if we could get a thumbnail of
what this does and just have a sort of
wolf now a flag up on the side with a
thumbnail that says Wolfram Alpha
version or something what is this doing
this is great immediately for me I just
thought well I don't know which which
maybe I'm going to some weird
non-production Cole oh that's really
weird
okay another case be that as it may um
okay it's finally okay so when you say
some nail here's one potentially
suggesting okay I'm and I may not know
what I'm talking about here but let's
just try something like this so I'm
suggesting that we literally make the
thing that looks like that and says
something like and we put it over on the
right hand side here and we say
something like and we write over it or
something you know independent of the
concrete numbers if you used to feel
absolutely there are no numbers it's
just just the one shot corresponds to
this formula that would be my suggestion
both of us say at the site it is right
now it's nearly generic because
typically only at the bottom if there
are custom plots there will be a
different fine
certainly the designers could chime in
but I think would be more useful just
having no I don't think so I think it's
useful to see something about what
you're going to get what's the value of
the in the Institute calculator versus
the Alpha result right I mean what's the
benefit of returning that result in in
product on this page versus considering
going straight alpha with a submit
because there many formulas that won't
be an alpha yeah here is that this is a
formula repository well one can you know
submit individual users can submit
formulas etc I mean personally I think
this becomes a lot more useful when the
formula isn't just an algebraic formula
and when the formula has actual
computation in it um but that's I think
the next step with this but all right
how many formulas do we actually have
prepped here 200 okay and how many
formulas do we convince given me 800
something to do okay and what's your
role in doing them Bob so so he has all
the metadata and I'm turning into
resource objects and submit but is that
an automatic process yeah it is okay so
the the manual part that still serve
should be done smartly is the examples
which I talked to Jason about okay you
know that can't have to all happen
initially if we have some became go
through as the time goes by and make
each page better whenever we want you
know that's fine okay and what about the
submission notebook I think that the
goal for formula was you know we have a
decent collection a good collection
already to get that out and live
discipline don't book well I proposed
number of fields and did a very rough
layout of what what it should consist of
okay well so do we need to look at that
right now no I don't think so okay back
on the the resource page I do have
another question we added you know we've
just added some routing for the Wolfram
Alpha case I'm wondering about adding
some text or a little bit more
explanation about what else this
resource offers you know if we if the if
someone is landing here just after you
know searching up a formula
you know there's a useful form and you
can go to Wolfram Alpha but it doesn't
really advertise the you can integrate
this into the Wolfram language part
isn't about what the examples are
supposed to do integrated though I don't
see using this formula for anything it
kind of shows results you know in the
meaning so like if you do they typically
give you not always go off or maybe a
surface has some of the variables
changing and shows you there you are in
the big picture like we could add such a
plot making for instance here yeah I
mean I don't know what the original
objective of the formula repository was
to allow a large number of you know
fairly random formulas that have occur
in different specialized fields to have
sort of a a home page on the web so to
speak and I mean that's really what
we're trying to do here I think we're
dealing with breadth not you know we
don't there's no point in repeating what
we've already got in alpha at least so
long as alpha is exposed in some way on
the web to my mind you know the real
interest comes in people submitting
formulas or us being able to get people
to you know contribute additional
formulas but again do we have a
framework that allows them to be not
just algebraic formulas not yet we don't
have before we have ionised or a fair
and reasonable
lopa fication of some things that's also
differential equation does the fact we
would them whatever in conjunction this
formula well I mean if it's in the
function repository we could expect to
have something on the function
repository that would work yeah right
let's move on here I mean to me this is
looking ok I mean it's not
yeah I think what I'm what I was hoping
to to run by you or get some input on
was even just adding like a tagline in
the header or something in the nav bar
for you know link to a workflow of how
to integrate a formula in tear Wolfram
language code some some indication that
you know you you come to this page and
you see a form unless you know what
you're looking for examples are supposed
to before if you scroll down to them yes
well so what are you looking for I mean
what is the right way to integrate this
see I think these formulas where there's
you know where the formula itself is a
fairly simple form is not an immediate
slam-dunk useful thing if this formula
had some weird complicated you know
differential equation or an
interpolating function or something like
this in it then it would be immediately
useful to do it in Wolfram language but
when it's in this form it's like okay
fine you can do it there you have to you
know substitute values to variables but
it's kind of trivial because you're
doing I mean it's the reason that for
example units and not as widely you know
now that we have units integrated into
both language they're very useful but
and people use them even when they don't
need to use them but for many many years
you know once you're in the middle of a
computation you don't need units I think
we should just go ahead with what we
have here and you know we're going to
get more interesting use cases for from
language integration when the formula is
more complicated that makes sense sir
okay let's let's move on because I
really want to cover some other things
updated favicon
what is the favicon is that the favicon
that's a really weird favicon
considering they mostly don't have
integrals in them specific repository
but we need to create something for the
web to have it's kind of like you see
the repository icon up in the tabs yes
so that's what is this icon here because
this icon doesn't make a lot of sense to
me that's our current formula repository
icon so as it comes from
I don't know if you've previewed it or
not I think of it as a matter of
switching out symbols we can but it
didn't get any pushback on these so well
Michael do you want to comment on this I
would pop it I think the Omega on the
fire is fine I believe in the cosine
yeah I mean otherwise this is it's
that's not what it's about if you can
suggest something different
Michael okay I mean maybe some things
that are more like you know a mass of
the earth type you know symbol I mean it
seems to me like that probably the most
iconic formalist of the world are F
equals MA equals MC squared and yeah
equal you something that represents
these things and just equals y equals
will be a relevant thing here okay look
I'm you know let's let's do another
iteration on this okay let's go back
you're talking about this fav icon here
well it's what we derived from this
whatever this is but it should right
she's just saying that's a known issue
that it's okay okay Gossett okay all
right let's let's move on because we
really need to move through these things
so let's let's move on to the neuron
that repository if we can which means if
Jason wants to drop he can do so
so the link you're going to now is
showing all the latest in certain design
and style changes but with only a
limited content okay all the content is
on the actual deployed page okay there's
Megan here by the way yeah I'm here and
in fact that there's grey boxes that's
just because we haven't taken the time
to fix them on this deployment
okay is this really is this kind of
ransom note like font treatment really
what we wanted you would ask for that as
far as those delineations of wait for
that part of the speech I better to get
away to wait if we can get it down to
that okay I leave it to you I wouldn't
put anything go ahead bumping up trained
on to be the same as the data set mm-hmm
I don't know it's going to look like for
other ones also over here I thought we
were going to have the the actual you
know real content as opposed to the
superstructure being in a slightly
darker or thicker font we can do that
okay all right so what am I supposed to
be looking at here this looks perfectly
decent as are these are these something
that's what they are intended to be
they're not closable really yeah we have
we have a branch where we've have
closable implementation but we don't
have designed for it yet we still need
to the yeah the functionality is going
to come in with function repository for
sure okay all right fine but this is
this is now getting to be quite long
page do we want jump down links at the
top for example to construction notebook
well that that's something once we have
the closing tech in place then we can
have one section of examples of fine
fine so then there won't be as long okay
well this looks okay except I think that
really doesn't look great let's take a
look at something which has a longer
name well that doesn't look as bad
actually
I wish Jeremy what can we do to help
with this
well how crazy is it to force two lines
because that's that's why this one looks
fine
not crazy yeah we'd have to look at a
shorter case but this I agree this looks
pretty decent in parses really well
we're forcing two lines on the landing
page now I see well an untrained on
could be treated could we treat that
differently and could we fake lower case
it or is that not a good idea well so up
at the top why isn't this clickable why
isn't this copy paste of all this this
title should be copy testable as a
resource talking about that night
disagree should be something you want a
copy and paste like into just a text
editor because we have the example below
where no we have examples but I mean the
thing you want to do basically a hundred
percent of the time from this page is
get the resource data object out I'll
get the net model out I can't be plain
text out of every website I go to all
the time and I think if there's nowhere
where this name appears in plain text
this copyable that's a problem yeah okay
what other people think Megan do you
have an opinion I mean usually I just go
down to the net model art and copy it
from there well right I mean it usually
works just as well to copy the title and
then all you have to do is add quotes to
it it's I don't think it's a big deal
but all right okay okay all right what
else do we have to discuss about this
and the only thing that's really being
changed that's important for 11:3 is the
evaluation function stuff right and
Megan I assume you're on top of actual
items that need the evaluation function
yeah it's the ones that are named role
model so it's easy to find them oh I see
okay okay but and and as soon as that
goes in you know when does 11:3 go on
the relevant service so that we can
actually try it here
didn't someone I'm asking are you asking
me I don't know but but or I'm asking
bad or whoever knows that's not
something I'm currently tracking for
this I can find out them okay I think
running on the servers no but in other
words well are you saying okay maybe all
we need to do is get the appropriate
fields in the definition notebook with
the evaluation function and then it's up
to net model it's up to the client side
running of the thing to do the right
thing with the evaluation function yeah
it's good point three necessary we can
update the repository asynchronously so
you're telling me that as soon as we put
in an evaluation function in the
repository how is it going to flow
through correctly in that model who's
dealing with that so I have the
repository set up so that each resource
can have versions and the versions can
have independent Wolfram language
dependencies okay so for the same for
the same resource object and lend to
user will get the eleven to version 11 3
user look at the 11 3 version that's
magnificent how do you do that there's
there's you know we're storing both on
the cloud and the client you have to
call from the client and the client
includes their version number in the
request yeah okay fine
so it negotiates the correct version
yeah great okay so if the old version is
named role model and we change the names
and how older versions have different
names and there's many different
resource objects-- ok there's no problem
having different resource objects we can
leave some off the home page if we want
it that's what we want to do we don't
forget in role model versions off the
home page but have them I guess be
available if there's code that depends
on the rest and my point of view is if
it's the way that you use it is
different and we should make a new
if the input to output if you know if
instead of outputting I agree you know
putting probabilities that means it
should be a new object it's that's
what's happening here it's all good okay
okay anything else we need to discuss
about neuron that repository so what I
think I was curious about was how
actually do with so a lot of networks
that we've got there are you gonna work
in eleven point three so what is the
sort of protocol for adding those things
Twitter's wait until eleven point three
comes out and then no I mean what we're
being told is that Bob has a thing that
negotiates the version when the client
requests the data so what happens if
there is no version for eleven point two
and it's an 11 point to client
requesting it what does it do just gives
you a warning that says this is for
eleven three and it probably fails to
import or I don't know it will still
download it which maybe you shouldn't so
I was in the sound versioning that
there's a that means is yes the port was
added exactly for this purpose but the
question is about the websites so like
if all the new models on the websites I
eleven point three models that no one
can run then don't worry about the
website is not an announced website
twelve you know in this everybody's
going to sweb site should we put up
things that no one can use or should we
wait until at least one person who can
use them that's a different issue my
feeling is we should not put them in the
future we should not have them on the
website I mean once the website is
announced we should not have them on the
website until people who are until for
example the cloud can use them well make
sense yes that makes sense
which means basically that there is a
version out there in the world ok can we
move on to the next item
yeah
hmm okay all right function repository
well where are we at with this so can
somebody give me a demo go go ahead
right so right now we're at the point
where we're working on building content
for the review meetings that we were
going to have with you you'd request it
we use the cloud deployed version of
shingles and so Cody is putting that
together
currently once that's ready we'll we
should be ready to start reviewing
content with you okay do you have a case
but all of the mechanisms are now
working is that right Rick has
everything relevant in terms of how the
functions are defined how they're how
they're displayed etc that's all working
is that correct yeah so far so good
there's still some minor improvements
that could be made but it is a
functional I suspect once we start
looking and real content we'll find
things we want to do change or update so
there there are some loose ends we
haven't really trimmed up just yet
knowing that we're going to have to go
through that after the content as well
oh rick is a great code one on the it's
not on the public repository right it's
on the RSS no it's an artist all right
let me send you one more line before you
do that Steven okay so you know this
deployment that we've been looking at
has a bunch of test resources on it so
this is pointing your client T is the
test deployment of the resources that's
what that's what system service will
eventually do okay let's see what this
does
okay so what's that doing so that was
loading the grey code function and then
doing a probably downloaded function
resource Pacolet and as well and then at
the resource object you have another
example that was goofy that downloaded
something again so that's obviously
wrong did you see that no sorry I was
looking for another example okay take a
look it's
that's wrong you're right that is wrong
I think the short name it doesn't cache
it which is something we need to fix so
if you had a spot I think it'll work if
what there we go oh yeah okay so then if
I look at resource object are you
telling me that there's a resource
object called gray code now on the cell
okay cool so the website of things is
you know that we've got a spine
formula in priority so we're cleaning up
a bunch of those things we should we
should put function ahead of formula
because I think formula is looks like it
has some extra tentacles in it well the
bottlenecks on function is there's we
don't really have a path line pipeline
of content coming in I'm well aware but
I mean who is working on any content
he's been working on content not that
I'm aware of okay who was the main the
main approach for content that we took
out of our last meeting was that Ric
would work on some automated tools to
scrape existing packages the external
packages has not started I know he's put
some work into it I haven't seen or
reviewed any of that yet okay do we have
a big list of things that are ready to
be put into the function repository as
soon as the function I mean in other
words things that need to be recast so
that they are appropriate for the
function repository
yeah we've been collecting a number of
lists for that I mean we go back to math
sauce from 1989 I'm sure we've got
things from there yeah before the web so
really the next step is to take those
places do some automated cleanup that
Rick is going to assist in and then get
them on to some cloud deployed pages so
that we can but I think it's important I
think once we have this available people
inside the company can start to deploy
this and we also have to have function
repository on the
eternal private cloud which I hope is
not going to be too difficult and then
people can start to deploy things both
both internal functions and external
functions mm-hmm I mean I really think
we just need to get this out and ready
even if it does not have a lot of
content initially yeah yeah my main
concern is is those things we discover
once we start putting real content in
there they're gonna you know almost
always so far have been like metadata
changes or extra features we need to
know that's why we should stop putting
content and right that's currently what
we're working on
okay so how is Cody doing so the design
for the shingle pages is finalized yes
no he's working on a generic cloud
deployed version of the shingle okay so
where are we at with getting the design
for the shingle pages no it is we
designed they're just being implemented
can I see the design let me try and find
that real quick okay unless you have a
link on hand I think it's quite nice but
there would be nice to have one thing
called argument pad on like if you have
not used it if you an idea how many
important things come from away that
would be useful
I mean we could say I know why it says
type function i can substract of
resource yeah okay so then we could say
here description find the gray code for
an integer and then arguments perhaps it
will have the
carrot carrot link to the website which
will show you how to use it okay let's
take a look at this other template you
know deep with little fill and fill in
fields which templates
well I mean we do this for our functions
where you can get complete the
autocomplete template user assistance I
guess for somebody who doesn't know this
function going to the web page is a
little bit too much broke if you just
want to eat the code also then writing
the code so seeing what this thing takes
which lot might be very nice we're great
I'd be surprised if autocomplete or user
assistance I mean it's gonna be easy to
implement why
well first argument some values here you
know I'm not not to resource function
yourself and then the patterns would
have to be installed dynamically instead
of that's right that's fine there's
plenty of stuff that's installed
dynamically okay so one project
management thing somebody should talk to
parse about the user assistance about
you know getting this implemented for
user assistance who is being the
function repository content side is
sushma functionality is mono okay so I
think that will be for men who go and
deal with that okay do we think that
this page do we think this design is
final
and I understand why that's blue though
why is that blue that we had modeled a
lot of this after the resource or the
mm-hmm the reference yes I think you'd
wanted this yes you said make it blue
because it was clickable and linked to
itself which was consistent with what we
doing in function pages no but then it
should be the whole thing yeah okay
resource function of that whole thing
should be clickable okay um yeah I guess
I need to see some more examples here I
mean and also that font is awfully
smaller for I mean is it really the same
as what we're seeing in a main function
page I don't think so it meant to be how
no it matters but if I'm in Italy that's
right
I can go compare the text sizes and
update anything that doesn't match
exactly fine I mean let's let's go for
example to I don't know I know I'm
typing something with such a long name
but okay so this is what we're supposed
to be analogous to okay and I don't know
whether we I'll be following over with
it with the blue hair and things and
also this definitely looks smaller
though although that's on the right it's
responsive so if your page is a little
narrower it's gonna get a little smaller
it's probably matching that whip I see I
see I see okay fine and this will have
the same responsive design yes yeah and
we decided the gray instead of blue
because these might be external people's
functions we're kind of the blue and is
endorsed by us and the gray is you know
line at your own restaurant
okay and why are we changing this from
details and options to details details
and options yeah it would be easier to
read and we have a chance we should
change it
options work winters sure you have
options I think no I mean the uppercase
options open close yes okay okay okay
and these things here are those really
it's not really the right font inside
there seems very weird to me I think
Jeremy we were in the process of
updating the font we were using for
those Jeremy until you have been working
on something with that I think that's
Roboto I can double check in my file but
definitely yeah and this looks kind of
goofy here this doesn't feel like the
thing that it you know somehow that's
got to feel like it is a the name of a
function it's got this weird decoration
here I don't know what Jeremy do you
have any thoughts about how to improve
that because it just doesn't look right
here Dave cannot stay because if you
have a moody arc function that's too
confusing I'm I'm still sometimes
uncertain about the usability of this
blob form entirely what do you mean by
that I mean in this code if you were
typing it out you would I assume you
would type out resource function of
string name instead of copying and
pasting a blob into it but bins under
pills yeah it depends on the person I
mean in other words if you can paste the
blob from the example page here I would
just paste the blob particularly if some
place here I mean this is where I just
need a place like right here you know if
I could just click that well the
question is what am I going to get if I
click each of these things right and
that's the same as sue that I was had
you know addressing in the in the
formula repository thing because I'm
asking the question you know I would
like a place immediately on this page
where I can say great I want one of
those boom I click it right possibly
even a visible thing that says copy
somewhere
I know I can just click it to go get
that thing and paste it into my notebook
am I making sense yeah I mean it's the
same issue that we have in I mean I've
noticed the neural net repository I've
noticed it occasionally in the data
repository that going and hunting
through the examples to find what you
want can be kind of annoying well the
first two examples I mean if you know
how to use the page the first two
examples are surf consistent across
support no they're not no they're not
that case is where it says random sample
of blah blah blah as the second example
right which is not the right thing I'm
saying right because we don't want it
yeah we don't want to generate a 100
megabyte output asset but still it would
be useful and I think we need a design
thing where where you can just go ahead
and get that so here for example if I go
what was I looking at let's say this one
here okay this one bizarrely by the way
did I send you mail I happen to load
this one up it was like 8 gigabytes it's
big this one's really big ok to open in
cloud download example notebook it's
just as copy to you know Kathy Wolfram
language input I think you have to show
a box-like thing that looks like this
yeah we could do that if it was an icon
that looked like one of these blobs if
I'm making sense it looked like
something like this and just said copy
well in these in these cases I think
we've got a couple of different things
we're achieving for the data you want to
copy resource data of string name for
use for the function you want to you
don't want you want the output of
resource function of string name is what
you want to copy well yes in that case I
agree but here ok
just address the question why is this a
gigabytes does it need to be it's just I
think we have Eleanor Penn Dewey okay
fair enough
um okay so okay so the issue is we want
to be able to copy the resource object
and the target well we want to copy that
you're saying we want to copy three
things we want to in the case of the
resource function we might want to copy
the function blob output as well as
copying the text version it sounds like
that's what you want I I think copying
resource function of string name serves
the purpose no but but that's the whole
point if we're gonna have that blob form
people need to be able to copy that blob
form although I admit that that blob
form is not looking very convincing yet
here copying pasting the blob form is
going to look kind of nasty because we
can only copy text so it'd be the import
form of the blob well but when it paste
sent to the notebook what's it gonna do
it's going to paste in the input form of
the blob why because we can only put
text onto the clipboard
but can't we have box data in that text
so yeah we can
so we'll paste just fine right if you
paste in a text editor you'll think
something terrible happens if you paste
it in a notebook you'll be fine right
and who would expect that this would be
reasonable in a text editor given that
it has some weird graphical form okay
but the other issue is this f of X as
Michael points out is not going to make
it for that F of that but F of thought
is very obscure mathematics what do you
mean obscure mathematics it's the modern
form to represent pure function and
abstract mathematics ever stood okay
well what about F of a gray bar a you
know aspect ratio two to one gray bar
for example
I'm not sure that this is the right
iconography look multiple things are
wrong here first of all keeping this
single get rid of it totally and somehow
more emphasized the function character
on the right somehow
I'm not quite sure how with some without
duplicating the opening square bracket
on the right like apply doesn't help us
because because then okay but look we
really need to get the sort of the full
flow of one of these some you know
resource function pages done even if
this is what it's looking like right now
we're going to have to change this but
let's not worry about that yet let's
just get these pages starting to you
know flow through but a little wolf icon
work here that's we tend to go there a
lot but it seems like it might fit here
okay it's also the language function and
then matching the fonts right this ad
should just inherit the full fin here
yeah yeah yeah I should be the same
thing everywhere and I'm not convinced
about wolfing this page I mean maybe the
better thing to do would be to have this
dot be some kind of motif that can just
be a dot there okay just a plain dial
well I'm thinking that then the dot
would have to be carried through here
and so the this sort of minimal size
icon for the function repository would
then be a dot a circle disk I think we
should try that it's not fantastic but
let's try it
because we're still trying to grapple
with how these things work
um but you agree the font size it should
just inherit the surrounding text font
write the code fun I would think so yes
yeah okay I would think so I'm not
convinced about that dots thing why
don't we
graphically can at the height would be
nice to have two surrounding one but if
you use a lot of them any piece of code
mister additionally great boxing around
I don't wanted to disturb the height
spacing of course really are the Box
should be really tight I think he says
otherwise it'll be okay fine let's try
that okay but but the most important
thing here is just to start being able
to actually deploy these okay and yeah
it's our first target is to get those
out to use and they're in the review
process okay fine API repository and you
should have the packet repository on
here I have to say that having looked up
in the formula repository here it's nice
but I don't think it's gonna blow socks
off initially so I feel like in terms of
priority you know the function and API
repositories have much clearer missions
even though both of them have a lack of
content right now long list of ideas for
API difficult implements you have to be
implemented okay so I'm asking the
question the design of the documentation
pages for the API repository where are
we at with that we haven't touched
anything in the resource system context
I mean the last thing we have is from
the previous API project well we need to
get that out of mothballs and start
working on it and I would say that if we
have to throttle back a bit on the
familiar repository we should do that
but we should keep pushing forward on
the functions and api's and I mean the
next one that's clearly going to be
important is I mean there's several more
that are important and we we got to
figure out how to speed up these
repositories because you know I know
each one of these has had its own weird
tentacles and so on yeah but I'm gonna
be the same for the API repository no I
to figure out for that as well um
package would be nice to bundle with
function repository well or packet
repository is what we're really talking
about that right I think the first step
is to get the packet system so that we
can you know is to make a documental
version of the packet system which I
don't think should be so hard where are
we at with that which is just pure
language documental forget about
shingling and things like this right I
think Todd had that on his agenda 14
years ago manager tools have been in the
language is great working for a long
time but this we've never really had
documentation are you talking about
doing that or having a layer above it
but documentation I'm not sure I don't
know whether that layer is usable I
think one of the issues is right now
it's pure public backlights which is
also what we're doing with the function
repository right now until we have the
marketplace set up I think I think
getting packets to kind of be a
first-class object in the language would
be the first step before we start moving
towards packaging it as resources well
fair enough
so if you want get a design meeting
together about that subject okay okay
all right
I think I need to run here um okay
anything else we need to cover right now
no I think that's good okay see you guys
soon thank you